What are we holding on
somewhere i'll never suspect
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
justice league 2 in justice league 3 video the
breakdown of the story the zack snyder revealed
with all of his storyboards he pretty much gave us
what the entire story for all the justice league
sequels is going to be so there's a lot of stuff
here if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos obviously we
just got done watching the justice league snyder
cut but careful for spoilers if you did not watch
that movie because like the last 30 minutes of
the movie and the epilogue tagged on at the end
pretty much tell you where the story is going next
in justice league 2. but what happened is way back
in december 2015 jim lee said that zack snyder
brought him on to the project to draw these giant
like 10 foot tall storyboards with the pitch for
justice league 2 and justice league 3 to convince
the studio to spend the money to make all three
movies but what i'll do is i'll just read what the
story is and talk about where this all fits in and
with the studio warner brothers and zack snyder
has said about the chance of us actually getting
this story of the sequels in some form or another
but the big question is whether or not that's
going to be a movie or it's going to be as a comic
book so he starts by saying although originally
pitched as one film we believe the character arcs
of our heroes and villains along with the epic
battle with darkseid which unites the league
the world and the entire dc universe warrants two
films instead of just doing one sequel he goes on
to say however this does not mean that you have
two films centered on dark sides invasion rather
justice league 2 would be a very grounded personal
and character-driven film that would follow the
justice league both together and separately as
they mend old wounds on the road to becoming
better and stronger heroes while lex luthor
recruits a league of his own the injustice league
made up of revenge driven villains introduced in
the hero solo films dr maru from wonder woman 2.
that was actually dr poison i think originally in
zack snyder's idea they would have introduced dr
poison in a bigger way during the sequel to wonder
woman captain cole from the flash movie ormond
black manta from the aquaman movie and the riddler
from ben affleck's version of the batman movie
these villains would link all of the dc films
together now remember this is back in 2015 so it's
the original version of the spin-off films those
wound up changing a little bit like the aquaman
movie changed a little bit the flash flashpoint
movie has changed a little bit the wonder woman
movies have changed a little bit then he goes on
to say like empire strikes back in the last harry
potter film justice league 2 would end with a
cliffhanger revealing only at the end of the
film lex and his league are connected to dark side
then flash forwarding five years into the future
where darkseid has taken earth that's basically
the nightmare future that we see at the end of
the justice league snyder cut then he goes on to
describe the hero's arcs through parts 2 and 2a
with lois's help the back from the dead
superman will learn to become clark kent again
feeling more human than ever he and lois start a
family remember how they teased lois was pregnant
wonder woman would reconnect with the amazons and
her mother eventually becoming their new queen
and rejoining these isolationist warriors with
the outside world meaning connecting themschira
with the outside world aquaman with the help
of mira will bring the seven kingdoms together
seven kingdoms of atlantis originally becoming
the one true king building a new alliance between
the oceans and the surface that was what the
whole unite the seven tagline was about unite
the seven kingdoms of atlantis before atlantis
sank into the ocean the flash will free himself
from the past releasing his father from prison
with cyborg's help and learning how to master
his time traveling abilities literally
becoming able to be in two places at once
cyborg will evolve both into the modern day god
of the digital age and into a human once again
and batman will ultimately sacrifice his life
for the unlikely friends and the woman he loves
leaving behind a legacy that will never truly die
but he starts with the plot of justice league 2 by
saying the justice league united we open with the
justice league in action during a natural disaster
working as the efficient powerful team they become
weeks after the first justice league movie ends
they act together they save lives in the aftermath
the justice league return at the only headquarters
they know the bat cave bruce secretly meets with
lois both of them still searching for lex luthor
the meeting ends after lois tells bruce
that superman needs her more than ever
bruce knows lois is hiding something else probably
the pregnancy he was gonna set this whole batman
lois lane romance through the sequels that
would play out then he talks about lex luthor
recruiting the injustice league meanwhile deep in
the brazilian jungle lex locates dr maru that's dr
poison from the wonder woman movie still alive
experimenting on herself prolonging her life
and testing new chemical weapons on unfortunate
human lab rats like an obsessed stalker maru has
spent decades collecting information and artifacts
on diana and the amazons now that diana has become
known in the world lex offers meru a chance at
revenge the same revenge he wants on diana's
friends superman and batman maru accepts in the
atacama desert with meru's help lex breaks orm in
black manta out of the desert prison where they
were imprisoned at the end of the aquaman movie
outside of central city in iron heights
penitentiary lex finds leonard snark captain cold
where he was left at the end of the flash movie
or where he would have been left at the end of
the flash movie it offers him a chance to advance
his weaponry and take down the fastest man alive
upgrade his cold gun with alien technology then
there's this whole sequence with them intercutting
between the injustice league and the justice
league characters in metropolis superman asks lois
lane what she was going to tell him as he hears
the second heartbeat inside of her back in the
louvre in paris wonder woman and one of her fellow
themskerans who came to warn her about steppenwolf
apparently in the previous version of the movie
there was an amazon instead of them just firing an
arrow so an actual amazon came to warn her about
steppenwolf they're trying to find a way back to
themyscira but because of the magic that zeus put
on it they can't do it without some help from the
lasso of truth then as the lasso of truth is
giving diana all these visions she suddenly
sees a vision of herself as a dark diana as the
goddess of war battling with superman she kills
him this is probably another vision of a potential
nightmare future back in central city barry allen
is at the courthouse with iris west and cyborg and
with the help of the rest of the justice league
they agreed to reopen his father's case so this
is just the beginning of him getting him out of
prison then back in atlantis aquaman and meera are
in this fierce battle to unite the seven kingdoms
of atlantis they're at the last seventh kingdom
called the unseen and even though he winds up
beating their king in battle he refuses to rejoin
the other seven kingdoms so he hasn't completely
united quote unquote the seven at this point
yet then back in the bat cave cyborg is helping
alfred upgrade all of batman's technology
to hyper tech level batman moves deep into
the canadian wilderness doing recon following
a lead on lex luthor and winds up running into
the riddler who seems like he's been awake for
days maybe weeks he has this giant beard there's
writing all over the walls it's kind of like the
inside of the cell at the end of the shazam movie
he says luther asked the question and i had to
know the answer he reveals that lex luthor came
to him with information about the anti-life
equation remember that was going to heavily
figure into the sequels it was the big symbol
that was carved into the ground whenever darkseid
and then later steppenwolf smashed it with their
weapons apparently there was this riddle connected
to the secret of the anti-life equation and the
riddler solved it and that's what drove him crazy
then as he reveals all this information to batman
he winds up killing himself then as batman returns
from the wilderness back to the bat cave and
alfred they reveal that lex luthor has found
all three mother boxes then at the three rivers
dam helicopters survey the area as lex is on the
scene and activates all three mother boxes his
true plan to destroy the justice league and take
the power of the anti-life equation for his own
then as the three mother boxes are coming together
and lex luthor thinks that he's achieved his
goal a boom tube opens darkseid and da'sod step
out as you would expect darkseid promptly takes
the power of the anti-life equation for himself
back in the bat cave superman learns of darkseid's
arrival and tells bruce please protect lois lane
she's my world she then reveals to batman that
he's not the father of her child superman is the
father of her child then back at the site of the
battle lex luthor reveals darkseid has the power
to kill superman in darkseid acknowledges him and
says i don't want to kill him i want him to submit
so that sort of explains why you have this evil
superman in the nightmare timelines and lex
luthor gives him the idea that it's all about the
girl lois lane saying that if you want superman
to submit you have to kill the girl even though
superman is supposed to be able to beat darkseid
be that powerful the reason why he's able to
kill lois lane is because he uses a boom to
to instantly travel to the bat cave and kill her
so that's how you wind up with this scene the
vision that cyborg got from the mother boxes of a
potential future with him cradling her dead body
and then breaking in dark side turning him in all
while this is happening you have all the other
members of the injustice league enacting these
attacks in different justice league people's home
worlds like dr maru goes and unleashes this poison
gas on themyscira killing all the other amazons
then apparently back in atlantis orm and
black manta were going to kill aquaman but
mira would survive that's how she winds up in that
nightmare timeline but not aquaman then back in
the batcave batman finds out what's happened with
darkseid killing lois lane superman turns on him
immediately becomes evil superman and tries to
kill batman then just as lex luthor is basking
in his victory over the justice league evil
superman shows up and burns him on the spot and
they sort of cut to black the transition as lex
luthor starts screaming and gets lit on fire then
they cut to five years later and you're in the
nightmare future like everything is a wasteland
on earth like batman is taking the survivors to
the bat cave or where the bat cave used to be
then we meet a new green lantern it's implied that
it's killwog the dead green lantern from cyborg's
vision that the mother boxes gave him but this is
him when he's first showing up to planet earth his
ship is crashing and he's trying to contact
someone from the justice league but no one's
picking up batman finds him and saves him from
the rubble of the ship then a bunch of pair demons
swarm them but they get saved by deadshot
another batman villain showing up who's now
working with him in the future flash shows up
helps them destroy the rest of the pair demons
then green lantern explains what's been happening
in the rest of the universe with darkseid and the
anti-life equation how he's paving his way
conquering the universe they go back to the
remains of the hall of justice underneath wayne
manor mira shows up with some drinking water
then batman explains their time travel plan to
green lantern how they're going to send the flash
back in time to warn him at the correct point in
time to save lois lane so that superman doesn't
wind up getting turned and though able to defeat
darkseid cyborg then reveals that he's created
the cosmic treadmill from the comics that flash
is going to use to time travel so while flash
and cyborg are busy sending flash back in time
you have batman the rest of the survivors trying
to distract evil superman with this big operation
darkseid sends in this huge army of parademons so
you have this massive battle going down superman
winds up killing batman which i think is from this
flash forward vision that cyborg gets but here's
the way that he killed him superman kills batman
with the original kryptonite spear that batman
had intended to kill superman with in batman v
superman but batman's planned his word to flash
travels back in time and is correctly able to warn
batman at the right point in time and plays to
save lois lane batman's able to push lois lane out
of the way of darkseid's omega beams just in time
to save her and superman shows up enraged but this
time instead of going after batman blaming him
for lois lane's death because she's still alive
now with superman's child he flies a dark side in
a rage and starts fighting him then in present day
darkseid starts a full-scale invasion of earth
with his fleet like he talks about at the end
of the snyder cut and they have their version of
the avengers end game final battle on earth with
pretty much every character from the dc universe
you've ever heard of coming back in the way they
end things seems very similar to the iron man
avengers end game ending with him sacrificing
himself to snap the infinity gauntlet batman winds
up sacrificing himself to land the killing blow
on dark side and destroy him completely then in
the aftermath lois lane eventually gives birth
to her child they name it bruce kent after bruce
wayne in honor of his sacrifice but remember she's
with superman he doesn't have any power so he
doesn't become superboy or anything like that
but in 20 years there's this ceremony where
commissioner barbara gordon is honoring
batman's sacrifice 20 years before she tells lois
when are you going to tell him looking at her
son that the secret she'd been keeping this whole
time is that her son bruce kent was secretly
bruce wayne's child as batman's true son he winds
up taking up the mantle of the next batman don't
know how everybody feels about that lois lane
giving birth to batman's child one of the spiciest
things i've ever heard of them doing in a dc movie
then the moment you go out on in justice league 3
like the epilogue or the post credit scene you see
a shot of bruce kent in the cape and cowl rising
from the shadows in gotham with a bat signal
shining in the sky so he actually was going to
show us what bruce kent batman was going to look
like what his costume was going to look like as
you can see here this is jim lee's mock-up of it
his gauntlets look a little bit different but the
batman symbol on his chest is very similar to ben
affleck's frank miller inspired dark knight symbol
and for those of you that really wanted a man
of steel sequel like man of steel 2 zack snyder
did say that justice league 3 would have very much
been a direct sequel to man of steel it would have
just been done inside the justice league trilogy
so that's a whole lot of story there it'd be cool
if we got to see it in film at some point but
the way zack snyder talks about it the studio
has no plans to make those movies but he and jim
lee did talk about doing a comic book version of
this to pay it off so even if it's not in the
actual movies i think we'll eventually get to
see them do a version of this story everyone post
all your reactions in the comments below what do
you think about zack snyder doing this as a comic
book story he also did say that he wanted to do a
prequel story for ben affleck's batman in the dead
robin sort of his version of a death in the family
but while you wait for everything everyone click
here for my full justice league snyder cut ending
and then credit scene video with all those easter
eggs and click here for that brand new suicide
squad trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!